Okay, in addition to a variant cancer, I have lymphedemia.
So lymphedema is common with many other cancers, many conditions.
You can get lymph stasis.
You're recommend using a rebounder how much time should I use per day,
currently doing five minutes a day.
So there's pros and cons to doing the rebuilder.
I know the companies that sell the rebuilders, of course,
they push all the pros to it.
There is cons to doing it as well.
If you know that you have a tastasis to anything,
to bold, especially, you do it to be careful on the rebounder
that you're not bouncing too much, because that force,
it's a matter of physics with the trampoline.
That force goes up through your joints again.
And even though I'm not pounding on the pavement, that's good,
but you still get that rebound force that goes up through your spine.
So the amatastasis to the spine, especially,
I don't highly recommend the rebounder.
You have to be very careful with it, very gently with it,
or just do some walking on it.
You can also use the rebounder in different ways,
where you just get on it, do leg razors,
where you go up on your toes and down.
You can do that on the ground as well, but sometimes it's a little...
You do it flexing different muscles when you're on a trampoline,
doing that.
Just make sure you have something that you're holding on to.
And also with lymphediva in the lower extremities, especially,
doing any sort of motion.
So remember, your lymph system is an open-ended capillary system
with those capillaries.
Do not have a part to pump the fluid through like your arteries
and your veins do.
So they rely on contraction muscles.
So any time that you can do any type of muscular contract,
it doesn't have to be, you know, it doesn't have to be even walking.
It's certainly not running.
You could just do muscular contraction.
So even if you're sitting in the chair,
that you're writing it out in the alphabet, that's your toes,
you're drawing a picture with your toes.
You're using your imagination and drawing a picture
with your hands with upper extremity lymphediva.
You're contracting your muscles, you're moving your arms,
you're moving your legs, that's the whole idea.
So any type of motion is good,
but you contract the muscles, you push the fluid through the lymph
vessels and then there's one way valid.
About every two to four inches and it pushes the fluid
through then it can't go back down.
So that's the idea of getting fluid through your body.
So I think I have a couple of blog posts moving lymph,
that can be helpful as well.
There's a lot of information at Google that,
because there's actually some lymph specialists
that are doing massage therapy work for lymphediva,
which can be extremely beneficial as well.
So lots of things to think about that can help with that.
So how often should I do the remiller really depends
on some of the things that I just mentioned.
You can certainly do more than five minutes a day
and you certainly have to do more than five minutes a day
of different muscle contraction exercises
if you're really going to be able to lift.
So you've got to try to do it as often as possible.